angela rainer labour's deputy leader
writing demanding a fresh investigation
into what went on with the funding of
the refurbishment of boris johnson's
personal flat now today the electoral
commission has found that the
conservative party broke the law with
how it handles donations for that flat
it's really unusual jane to be
discussing uh donations in connection
with something that's uh effectively um
personal to a senior politician
this is uh money that's when went from a
tory donor lord brownlow to the prime
ministers uh to the prime minister
effectively to pay
for the refurbishment of his own flat
that otherwise he would have to meet out
of his own pocket normally when we talk
about donation scandals uh it's in
connection to money that just goes into
party coffers that's for campaigning so
this incident uh is very different to
the kind of thing we normally see
and in that report by the electoral
commission it appears to challenge
reassurances given by downing history
and the prime minister about what he
knew and when about the financial
arrangements for the financing uh of the
uh of the refurbishment of the flat uh
let's see what the electoral commission
uh uh what boris johnson told and
downing street told his personal uh
advisor for ministerial interest his own
personal watchdog earlier this year he
told christopher geit i have spoken to
the prime minister
who confirms that he knew nothing about
such payments until immediately prior to
media reports in february 2021 so that's
lord geit boris johnson's personal
watchdog
being told earlier this year in spring
that boris johnson knew nothing about
the payments now if you fast forward to
what the electoral commission that has
far wider powers now independent of
boris johnson what they said today they
revealed that the um that on the 29th of
november 2020 uh which is three months
before uh boris johnson claims he need
nothing the prime minister messaged lord
brownlow via whatsapp asking him to
authorize further at that stage
unspecified refurbishment works on the
redst on the residence lord brownlow
agreed uh to do that so we can conclude
from the electoral commission report
that boris johnson understood about the
existence of a trust understood that
lord brownlow was the person uh to phone
if he wanted even more money uh to pay
for his refurbishment um downing street
have just come back and said that in
that conversation
uh lord brandley wasn't saying i'm
funding this trust that i'm chairing uh
it was a blind trust uh lord brownlee
didn't reveal that he was the uh even
though he's a wealthy tory donor that he
was putting the money in himself until
the next day when he told a tory party
official that this is the case but
nevertheless the wide-ranging denial
that boris johnson gave his own uh
ministerial advisor earlier this year uh
looks like it's coming under significant
pressure this morning as a result of the
electoral commission's findings
and what about the christmas parties the
infamous christmas parties now at
downing street in the surrounding areas
they seem to be going up in number
that's right we now have a significant
number of events both in november uh
connected with the departure both of
dominic cummings and lee kane uh the
head of strategy and the director of
communications uh and then in december
parties involving the downing street
press office and operations team uh all
of them uh uh generating questions but
only one of them uh is the subject
of the uh investigation by simon case
the cabinet secretary that's the one on
december the 18th that took place in
downing street that allegedly involved
secret santas a wine and cheese board
that's the event that uh
boris john's former aide resigned after
she was captured on film laughing about
it let's hear how government ministers
have been talking about this this
morning
the cabinet secretary's investigation
will establish the facts surrounding the
following
allegations made of a gathering at
number 10 downing street on the 27th of
november
2020
a gathering at the department for
education
on the 10th of december 2020
[Music]
and allegations made of a gathering at
number 10 downing street on the 18th of
december
2020
now the primary purpose of the cabinet
secretary's investigation will be to
establish swiftly
a general understanding of the nature of
the gatherings
including attendance
the setting
the setting and the purpose
and
with reference to adherence to the
guidance in place at the time
now if required the investigation will
establish whether individual
disciplinary action is warranted
so contrary to what the prime minister
said yesterday it seems as if the simon
case inquiry will be widened out into
some of the other events in november as
well as those in december at its heart
uh simon case the most important civil
servant in whitehall has to define what
is a party and what breaks the rules no
easy task
especially whether it's a party or a
gathering thanks very much